hey what's going on everybody i am dave
rubin this is the reuben report direct
message for today
april 12 2021 and as always
don't forget to click that subscribe
button over there and that notification
bell and you may
just may see our videos in your youtube
feed you never know
you never know uh before we get to the
stories this week i want to tell you a
little
insider info on what it's like to work
at the reuben report because people want
to know people want to know what it's
like to work at the room and report
well first off last friday if you
watched our live stream on friday
i had my hair was a little flatter and
and there was a piece like flying out
over here
and we have a bunch of cards over there
cue cards like my guys tell me you know
when to wrap up or gotta move on or the
house is on fire series of other things
one is fix hair one is fixed air because
occasionally
despite the spray and all the stuff
there could be a piece flying out over
here
they did not pick up the card and i've
had to lay into both of them this
morning both of these guys
they were they were mass beatings that's
what we do around here at the ruby
report
and uh and anyway i got a haircut and
the reason that that's
relevant is not just so you get a little
insight oh speaking of insight actually
before anything else uh michael my
producer
is wearing the boot you guys know about
the boot you see these people wandering
around the boot you go what happened to
them uh he fell it was his
it was his birthday and did you drink
did you drink
he drank a tiny bit and he fell while
getting out of the car
and uh something happened to him and
he's in the boot and i took him
to the to the doctor yesterday for the
x-rays okay and we go to the mall
the doctor's place was in the mall you
really wanted me to do this didn't you
doctor's place in the mall and in the
mall literally everything at the mall
had something to do with race it was
bananas there were so many signs digital
signs regular science
uh stop asian hate stop hating asian
people defend aaip blah blah blah
walk by a uh like a cosmetic store
uh big sign i'm a queer black woman and
this is my life
we took a picture next to that one that
was fun i go into nordstrom
because i was going to buy a t-shirt and
i posted this on locals this morning so
you can see this actual image
we should have shown it here but if you
go to reubenreport.locals.com you can
see the image
at nordstrom department store they have
a section
for black uh i guess designers
and they tell you you know with the
whole list of the people that design the
clothes and then they're doing this for
inclusivity
except i'm pretty sure that's
exclusivity if you only have a section
for
designers of one color so anyway i bring
this all up because it was it's just
such like a piece of the stuff that i'm
always talking about here like they're
just pushing all this politization
and race stuff on us constantly
constantly and constantly it's not good
wonder if nordstroms is going to have a
special section for
white designers i wonder if that's going
to happen in any event people we've got
three stories for you
today they're all sort of ballpark
within the stuff that i feel we should
be talking about these days because it's
that that
confluence of culture and politics first
story
is that one of the black lives matter
co-founders is on a massive real estate
buying binge we're going to show you
some of the houses
that she's bought people often wonder
what happens to all the money right blm
is raking in a ton of money corporate
sponsorships
sure they're burning down cities with
antifa and the rest of it but they're
making a
whole lot of money and it's like are
they sending kids to college are they
doing anything positive with the money
well
this chick is uh buying a whole bunch of
houses including
in topanga canyon which is where the
girl who cuts my hair who came here over
the weekend lives
and she happens to be white and it's
basically a 99.9
white neighborhood anyway we'll get to
that in just a moment i don't really
care where people live based on the
color of their skin but if you're
running a blm thing
then i think you see my point uh then
the second story
this is actually breaking right now and
it's a whole mess and i kind of didn't
want to cover it but then i felt like we
we had to because you're not going to
see an honest assessment out of it
obviously on cnn or anywhere else
in in the mainstream corporate media as
my friend michael malus
calls it there were massive massive
riots yesterday
in minnesota this is a precursor to what
are going to be crazy riots obviously
uh after the results of the george floyd
trial
well the trial of the officer who killed
george floyd
we know that there are riots coming no
matter what happens whether it's fully
guilty whether it's fully innocent
whether it's
partial whatever it is like it's that
city is going to burn
well it's burning already right now
because of a newer shooting there's some
breaking video that we're going to show
you
and we're going to show you some of the
looting because the point is
it doesn't matter if the cops do bad
things or if there is a bad cop or
something is done unjustly and we're
going to show you all the video
none of that excuses burning down a city
none of that excuses
breaking into you know game stop and
stealing all the stuff or
going into a liquor store and taking all
the tequila you can't do it
and then finally uh the infallible
fouchy
he is very very confused by what's
happening in texas because you know
they've been open for about a month
and things are okay dead bodies aren't
piling up
everything's actually just fine the
numbers are tanking
and this doesn't fit the narrative that
dr fauci would like to get out there
because he seems to want to keep us all
locked in our homes alone and confused
and tired and nervous
so he was talking about that this
weekend we're going to get to that guys
before i do
anything else and i'm fired up and ready
to go and one other little
insider bit of info i'm trying to
actually finish my second book this week
so it's going to be an extremely
an extremely busy week my goal and i'm
actually saying this out loud so that i
can keep to my goal
my goal will be to finish it by friday
and then of course you go into
you know a couple months of editing and
everything else but like to actually
finish the bulk of it
uh this friday and i'll leak a little
bit more about
what it's out over the next couple weeks
and uh and then i'll tell you the
release date and all that good stuff
and people before i get to any of that
i've got the largest bag of coffee right
here
this is black rifle coffee people and
i'm thrilled
finally that they joined us as a sponsor
last week god that smells good
that is good stuff they joined us as a
sponsor last week and we really killed
it with them so i'm
hoping we will continue that black rifle
coffee company is a veteran-owned coffee
company serving premium coffee
to people who love america veteran ceo
and founder evan hayfer spent over seven
years
on the ground overseas with u.s special
forces
and as a cia contractor evan even
modified his gun trucks during the
invasion of iraq to grind coffee
anywhere giving back to those who serve
is at the core
of black rifle coffee company's culture
in 2020 black rifle coffee donated more
than 6 million cups
of coffee to deployed soldiers law
enforcement and medical workers through
their signature buy a bag give a bag
initiatives
this month black rifle coffee company is
introducing a new line of ready to drink
canned coffee
the new 15 ounce comes with 300
milligrams of caffeine per can
100 colombian coffee high quality
ingredients and an energizing blend of
mct oil and amino acids to fuel your
energy and focus
you for whatever mission lies ahead
whether you're on a big hunt or a
cross-country road trip ready to drink
300 gives you a convenient way to enjoy
premium coffee when you don't have time
or equipment to make your own brew be
among the first to try the new 302
delicious flavors caramel
vanilla and rich mocha i'm actually
drinking the regular stuff right now and
it is pretty
delicious order your coffee now at
blackriflecoffee.comruben and use promo
code ruben for 20
off your first purchase that is
blackriflecoffee.com
make your mornings better with black
rifle coffee and now back to me
all right i'm gonna have a sip of
delicious black rifled coffee
it really is good like it's just like
rich and good and dark and
really nice okay uh guys so so blm
i've talked about this group before and
let me preface this
this is sort of like the trans thing
where you feel like every time you bring
up a topic you have to do a little
preface
because i know that you losers at media
matters and at vox and huffpo are
watching and waiting for
any moment that you can selectively edit
anything i say so i try to go
ahead and get in front of the problem
even though your relevance is becoming
increasingly less and less over time but
blm
the idea that black lives matter the
idea of that of course i believe that i
also believe that
white lives matter and asian lives
matter and gay lives matter and straight
lives matter and all of those things i
believe in equality
i believe everyone should be treated
equally under the law that's pretty much
all a society can do that's what i
believe
then there is the organization black
lives matter which is the
self-proclaimed
marxist organization which until
recently had
some of its goals stated on its website
it still has some other goals on there
but that
included uh destroying the nuclear
family basically disassembling the
nuclear family they want
a takeover of the u.s government in
essence and they basically are in it
with the progressives right they're
they're in it they're in it and some of
the progressives are just being mugged
by that reality you may remember
way back when when bernie sanders was
running back in like 2015 basically
uh that he was on stage and black lives
matter protesters grabbed the mic from
him and he just
sat there like a little because he
was afraid that if he didn't if he made
a move even though everyone there was
here there to talk to him to listen to
him he knew if he made a move
that he was going to be called racist
and everything else so they've really
the progressives
and the black lives matter marxist
they've got this really
tight intertwined match made in hell in
essence
and uh obviously and then when of course
when you connect that to antifa
and just the destruction over the last
two years and roughly two billion
dollars worth of damage
and everything else i'm not a fan of blm
okay
that being said i've been saying how
well where's the money going and a lot
of people have been asking this they're
raising a ton of money all these
corporate sponsors you know you open up
uber eats and it's black lives matter
this you turn on apple tv black lives
matter that i just told you what it was
like at the mall black lives matter here
and there the other thing
um well some of the money apparently is
going to the founders because they're
doing
pretty well this is from the new york
post
the self-described marxist last month
and this is the co-founder
of black lives matter last month
purchased a 1.4 million
home on a secluded road in a short drive
from malibu in los angeles the topanga
canyon homestead
which includes two houses on a quarter
acre is just one of three homes
that khan colors owns in the los angeles
area okay so she's got a bunch of homes
here so we're going to show you some of
the homes right this is from the new
york post
so there you can see a bunch of the
homes some of them are 500 grand
uh you know 700 grand it looks like she
was trying possibly to buy a 5 million
condo in the bahamas and then of course
this 1.4 million
home in topanga now i want to be very
clear about something
i don't begrudge anyone making money and
spending that money how they see fit
i don't begrudge that absolutely to
anybody slightly i would begrudge it
to let's say politicians who all somehow
magically become rich
with you know their salaries that are
usually somewhat marginal or at least
you know not completely bananas and then
they use all their connections to become
rich
but i don't begrudge anyone that that
has any sort of business
or even a non-profit that that makes
plenty of money
what i think is interesting about this
is this woman has founded an
organization based on marxist principles
and she lives obviously like a true
capitalist
and has what was it was it five houses
five houses
five houses and looking at a condo in
the bahamas that resort sells them for
about five million dollars each i'm
guessing they're pretty
they're pretty freaking uh sweet uh
we've got a quote here from the ap
the foundation widely seen as the
steward of the black lives matter
movement says it took
in just over 90 million last year the
foundation says it committed 21.7
million in grant funding
to official and unofficial blm chapters
as well as 30 black led organizations it
ended 2020 with a balance more than 60
million
this marks the first time in the
movement's nearly eight year history
that blm leaders have revealed a
detailed look at their finances okay
so blm's listed existed for about eight
years
this is the first time we've seen any of
the finances and from what that stated
right there
in essence they have about 60 million
dollars in cash sitting there
and they've given away about 21 million
of it to black lives matter chapters and
other black organizations but like
what to do what do we know any like have
they sent anyone to college
have they built any buildings helped
build any infrastructure helped with any
housing any any other educational
purposes
started a tech company absolutely
anything we have no idea just to say oh
we gave them to the local black lives
matter
chapters well okay that means you might
have just given a whole bunch of money
to just a bunch of activists to do
whatever they want right like that
you're just paying salaries with people
and by the way this is how a lot of
non-profits work like they just get in
money and then you just see that they
they spend very little of the money
on what is mission aligned what the
people think that they're donating
to uh she also by the way it's not just
that she co-founded blm as a marxist and
then lives life as a capitalist
she also got a multi-million tv deal
multi-million dollar tv deal
because of the public profile obviously
that she got from blm you know i saw a
lot of people on
on twitter talking about the story also
pointing out
how topanga canyon which is this little
it's this little like hippie area it's
not too far from here it's this little
hippie area sort of near malibu up in
the hills
it's very rustic and bohemian
and it's sort of as if the 60s never
ended
i saw somewhere that it's only 1.4
percent
black now i don't as i said before i i
don't care where black people live i
don't care where white people live
that's great if people live in mixed
communities that if you want to live
around a lot of people that look like
your color i guess that's mine too
like i don't really care about any of
that but it would seem
odd that as her fifth house she would
spend 1.4 million dollars to live in a
place that is basically 99
white if you care about that sort of
thing
i don't really care about that sort of
thing anyway i mentioned this story not
because it's the most
important or the most relevatory or
something like that but
it's just it's important to note what
these people
are doing there is an entire corporate
structure
that now tells us we have to believe in
these things and if you if you don't
believe in these things somehow you're a
bad person or something like that
and it's like man this is the biggest
grift
going this is the biggest grip going you
just
take in money and money and money as a
non-profit and you pay out all of these
people and you
exist to destroy capitalism while you
while you
live as a capitalist i think you all get
the point okay
so i want to talk about these protests
that are happening in minneapolis right
now because you're probably not going to
see much of this
in the corporate press by the way i'm
going to start trying to say the
corporate press
instead of the mainstream media this is
an idea that my friend michael malus
i've had on the show a bunch has talked
about for quite some time by saying
mainstream media you're actually giving
them too much credit as if it is
mainstream
but i don't even know that anything is
mainstream at this point we've all been
frayed in so many different ways
so cnn yes it's it's not that it's not
mainstream meaning sort of the average
person
watches it who kind of always watch this
stuff but it's more that they just they
are people who are drawn to corporate
media
who like the sort of blue and on
narrative so i'm going to try to say
corporate media
more than me or corporate press more
than mainstream media but i think
i think you get the point either way in
any event there was a police
shooting in the last couple days that
has now spurred on
a whole bunch of riots so first i'm
going to start with a quote
here from the daily wire hundreds of
apparent black lives matter
rioters smash police cars vandalized the
police station
and looted businesses in minneapolis
after law enforcement shot and killed a
man during a traffic stop
after the man who had an outstanding
warrant allegedly ran
from police after they pulled him over
okay so we're going to show you
uh video of the incident right now it's
actually pretty graphic
the reason that i'm showing it to you is
because the quote that i just read there
from the daily wire which was from an
hour or two was after this video just
got leaked so this video
was just leaked and it's not that he
allegedly ran from police officers you
can see him actually trying to break
away
then we'll give you a little bit of
further context but i'm just putting it
out there right now
that this is somewhat disturbing to
watch how long's the video it's about 30
seconds or so
it's roughly about 30 seconds so if you
don't want to watch
obviously this would be a time to just
uh you know open another tab or
something so let's take a look
oh
oh okay so i'm not a big fan of showing
these things in general because i think
you know everything unless you're there
and really understand the dynamics
between policing
and you know when you especially when
you couple like the pr
angle and that everyone has to be
thinking oh my god everything is on
video and just like all of that
stuff and also maybe there's more
context of the video and everything else
but i but i will say a couple things
here because
it's important so first off the the
young man who is now dead uh
his name is dante wright he did have an
outstanding warrant and apparently
uh this was for a traffic violation at
first now you can see
they're sort of cuffing him and then he
breaks free like if you resist arrest
like
at a certain level all bets are off that
is not excusing being shot it really is
not and this is just one of these
complex things
now you can hear the female police
officer who i believe is the one that
actually did the
the shooting she shot with one bullet
from what i understand
she's yelling taser taser taser
and then i think she says oh after
he gets shot
the implication being that she made a
mistake or that she didn't have the
taser she actually had
uh she had the gun in her hand and we
have a quote here from the uh police
chief tim tim gannon this is just in the
last hour so he said it is my belief
that the officer had the intention to
deploy their taser
but instead shot mr right with a single
bullet
so look that's what he's saying she was
yelling taser taser taser if she made a
mistake that still doesn't excuse it
again you can't if the cops are
arresting you and you resist the rest
then all bets are off so this is just
one of those ones
where there's going to be such a
breakdown of what actually is true and
most people won't watch that video
and most people will use all of this
stuff for their own political purposes
so i wanted to just show it to you
because
obviously between what what's happening
not only with this right now we're going
to show you some of the riots in just a
sec
but this is all with the backdrop
obviously
of the george floyd trial and there's
going to be massive riots no matter what
if you
if you are a sane person and you own
private property
in minneapolis i would get out of there
i would get out of there right now
because they're not going to do anything
so we're going to show you a couple
videos of the riots that have come
because of this and the point of showing
you this
is not for glorification of any of this
but are any of these people who are
doing this stuff let's say
let's say their cause is completely just
right like let's just remove all the
other factors for a second let's say
your cause
of what happened to george floyd is
totally just let's say your cause in
what happened
in the video that we just saw to dante
is totally just does that
excuse any of this so let's take a look
let's get justice for dante let's get
justice and dante
chill out y'all they wanna they wanna
they wanna start with us okay so we're
gonna show you one more but i thought
that one was important because that one
could
start going viral in and of itself you
can't lift a giant cement block with the
implication that you're about to throw
it
at somebody you can't do that you can't
do that especially to police officers
who have guns now i believe he was shot
with a rubber bullet but the guy in the
back is yelling
justice for dante justice for dante but
do you think that burning down a city is
going to bring
justice for dante or do you want should
you organize non-violent protests right
should you organize uh teams of
non-profit lawyers to come to the city
and fight
and that sort of stuff now we could have
shown you a gajillion versions of stores
burning there's a game stop that got
taken out there's all sorts of just
crazy violence people dancing on cop
cars and breaking windows and just
just destroying buildings we're just
going to show you one
yes
turn up
[Music]
okay so there are quite literally dozens
of videos that are
more violent than that that we could
have shown you and again i'm showing you
these things
because i think to paint a full picture
of what's going on here
if you think that what happened to dante
was unjust and if you think the officer
intentionally did that and even if the
officer accidentally
right like if the officer accidentally
like let's give her the benefit of the
doubt for the moment
she thought she was going for a taser
she went for the gun like none of those
details even matter
the point is if you now burn down a city
destroy liquor stores destroy mom and
pop stores destroy gas stations and game
stops and everything else
who are you helping are you as that guy
in the first video was screaming
bringing dante
to justice are you getting justice for
dante
the answer obviously is no and we're
stuck in this really really horrific
cycle
and this is again where we don't have a
corporate media that will show us
anything honestly so i guarantee you i
guarantee you
if you watch cnn tonight or you
especially if you watch msnbc not that
you should do either one of those things
at least not without drinking um if you
do
if you do that you're not gonna get the
full context
of the video showing him breaking away
and everything else
and that doesn't excuse any of it either
right like that's why i'm trying to show
you a full
picture here and this is obviously going
to continue
and you know one of the things i was
thinking this morning as we were putting
this whole package together
i was thinking you know knowing that
there's going to be more massive riots
at the end of the george florida trial
no matter what like we all know it right
we all
know it it's here it's coming why aren't
we having more conversations like where
is the minneapolis police chief
or the attorney general keith ellison
who i believe actually wants these
riots to happen because he is a
progressive and he has professed
support for antifa before but shouldn't
we ever be having a pre-discussion
on what they are going to do shouldn't
shouldn't the minneapolis police
department
be making statements right now saying
you cannot i don't know whatever it is
i'm not a fan of curfews really but you
can't be out
you know uh destroying public property
after 10 p.m sure you can destroy
public property from 7pm to 10. but
after 10 you can't right i thought there
was that whole pandemic thing and all
that
but shouldn't they be making making the
rules of engagement known right now if
if the idea is that the state wants to
stop violence stop rioting stop looting
have law and order and all those things
shouldn't we be talking about that now
like because they know it's coming
and you know one of the other videos
that we that we didn't show you
was there were just like a bunch of kids
there or they're young men usually i
guess they're not kids
just jumping on cop cars breaking
windows and the cops just stand there
and it's like
okay i get it you know like they're not
trying to throw flame
on the fire here right they're not
trying to pour flame on the fire but at
some point like
breaking cop cars and breaking windows
and all that is a crime too
and the more that you acquiesce the more
that you think oh if we if we just let
them vent some steam or something and
destroy enough buildings maybe they'll
stop
it's like this isn't how a functioning
civil society can work
and uh and it's only gonna get worse so
i would love to see
and if some if someone wants to get me
in touch with any of these people i
would love to see
some advance warning on what the people
uh you know what the elected officials
and law enforcement of minneapolis are
going to do
in advance of the george floyd trial
decision because it ain't going to be
pretty
i want to do one other thing real quick
and then i got to jump at 11 30 on the
dot
uh today uh but fauci the infallible
fouchy
he was on msnbc this weekend and he's
very confused over what happened
in texas texas effectively opened up
dropped all those restrictions and said
it's back to life and if you go to texas
as you know it looks like 2019 the
restaurants and the bars are full and
open the ballparks are full
and yet we've seen cases in
hospitalization
since then continue to tick downward so
what do you make of that as
all of us look around and sort of try to
consider how safe it is to get back to
normal life
yeah you know it's it can be confusing
because you may see a lag and a delay
because often you have to wait a few
weeks
before you see the effect of what you're
doing right now
you know there are a lot of things that
go into that i mean
when you say that they've they've had a
lot of
uh activity on the outside like ball
games
i'm not really quite sure it could be
they're doing things outdoors you know
it's
very difficult to just one-on-one
compare that
yeah he just says a whole bunch of
nothing and that's what he has said
basically for a year at this point it's
not a couple weeks to see where that
spike would be because they've been open
for about a month
the numbers are absolutely dropping and
let's not forget when it's not just that
they've been open for a month
but before that they were largely open
meaning that they were more open than
say a place
like california or a place like new york
and they never got
those crazy spikes and even if there is
a bump next week even if there is
that does not mean it's automatic reason
to just lock us down and not let us live
this is not how humans are supposed to
be but fauci has gone so far with this
thing i just don't know how you can
trust him
at this point anymore he's a fascist
he's a he's a he's a complete and utter
fascist
a fauces by the way which according to
uh williams
according to uh webster's dictionary is
a person who's the highest paid person
in all of government
uh who tells everyone else to stay at
home all the time anyway
fauci fauci oh guys part one of my
interview with uh nick gillespie
from reason mag is up this morning he
was on the panel
on real time with bill maher with heidi
heitkamp when she called gina carano
a racist we unpack that much more he's a
he's a true libertarian and we had a
great it was it reminded me of
a little bit of more of the type of
interviews i did a couple years ago
where it was purely on the idea side of
things
not too much in the nitty-gritty stuff
of politics but about
about big tech about just how we can
have limited government and let
ourselves live and fight lockdowns and
all that stuff really enjoyed talking to
nick
so part one is up right now on youtube
the full episode is up at
reubenreport.locals.com
and according to the watch i'm not
wearing it's 11 30. i gotta go
have a great day everybody